♪ ("L'ARLESIENNE SUITE NO. 2"
PLAYS) ♪
Donald, there's some things
I really need
to speak to you about.
First, I have a question,
and it's a very normal question.
Are you wearing a wire?
Like any lady with a baby,
I need to know where's...
-The changing room?
-...the bar?
Do you need
one of my special massages?
That gets a big, two thumbs up.
Oh, yeah.
We could try that as well.
Angela, I thought we had
something special.
Nein.
Your intellect is matched
only by your sensuality.
Ooh.
Definitely an infestation.
-Oh, no!
-Hipsters.
Can't you put some poison down
or something?
-WOMAN: Dame Judy Dench.
-What can we do for you?
I'd like a tattoo
that will do me credit
when I'm skinny dipping
in Saint-Tropez.
Or flashing from the royal box
at the Albert Hall.
(IMITATES TRAIN)
(COUGHS)
♪ (SUITE TEMPO INCREASES) ♪
For the love of God!
(SCREAMS)
♪ (SUITE CONCLUDES) ♪